on va le poster dans un seul but
d'ailleurs rendre intéressant alors
qu'on parle d'un drame
[Musique]
et gris est un garçon simple à la
recherche de l'amour il rêve d'une vie
meilleure quand soudain il va échanger
satimo des skis contre une vie
trépidante de multimillionnaires
trouvera-t-il celle qui donnera
[Applaudissements]
capter complètement par hasard en fait à
l'époque je dansais souvent dans des
émissions de télé ouais et j'ai un pote
danseurs qui me branche pour un casting
j'arrive dans le casting il a joué avec
un journaliste en face de moi qui me
pose pendant une demi heure des
questions et je me dis bon c'est
forcément pour un homme pour une
émission de télé réalité mais je sais
pas du tout pourquoi j'allais dans quoi
je m'engageais à démissionner mais faut
quand même se rappeler que c'est des
scores cédé 6 millions et sur une époque
louis qui devient une énorme star et la
panique a tf1 on découvre un que tu as
un casier judiciaire et deux que tu as
tourné des films un petit peu érotique
j'imagine que tu as tu as plein plein de
propositions j'en ai eu j'ai été parfois
bien conseillés parfois un peu moins de
biens j'ai eu un gros regret c'est quand
angela llorente m'avait proposé de
présenter l'île de la tentation en fait
ouais et gérard louvet remet avait un
petit peu interdit de le faire en fait
d'accord et c'est le plus gros regret
que j'ai eus parce que depuis là je
pense que j'aurais pu continuer une
vraie carrière d'animateur et et les
mauvaises décisions on en a tous
présents les mauvaises décisions c'est
quoi ces tissus retour au boss de me
lancer dans la musique alors que j'étais
pas fait pour ça c'était personnes qui
fraudent chose en fait c'était plus un
délire qu'autre chose c'est quoi ta vie
aujourd'hui tu vis ou et c'est quoi ta
vie je vais la réunion depuis trois ans
et demi avec mes enfants mais pourquoi
la réunion parce que on est là vivait
là-bas au parti on voulait quitter la
france elle voulait aller là-bas vécu un
moment parce qu'elle est son frère qui
vivaient là bah ouais et comme elle
m'avait suivi - peu à perpignan dans ma
boîte et company qu'on voulait bouger
ans elle voulait aller au soleil j'ai
fait allez on y va et puis voilà on est
la bonne pizza vie de quoi là bas pour
être je fais de l'événementiel en ce
moment un peu moins mais j'ai fait
beaucoup d'événements sierre j'ai tenu
des restaurants pendant un petit moment
donc ils attendaient des enfants ils ont
raconté géographie les cherry l'a décidé
jumeaux les chéri j'ai tendu motta tapas
et ils font et c'est très triste une
amniocentèse parce qu'il découvre que
l'un des deux enfants c'était une chose
de différent or est atteint de trisomie
n'est donc elle nous dit encore filmer
les chéri j'ai peut-être un des enfants
qui ne sera atteint de trisomie ça se
confirme et donc elle nous donne cette
vidéo pour nous annoncer ceci regarder
ça veut dire quoi
mon corps
à 98
88 c'est énorme je pusse et
merci
vite
mais là ya pas de limite c'est-à-dire
imaginez la scène imaginez la scène on
va appeler le médecin on pose le
téléphone au mail téléphone parce qu'on
se dit qu'il va leur et là on écoute en
menaçant cette fois on prend avec la
petite musique un peu triste pour pour
pour que ça paraisse encore plus
dramatique on va le poster dans un seul
but d'ailleurs rendre intéressant alors
qu'on parle d'un drame y avoir des
indications et on l'est on déguise en
disant c'est pour vous parce qu'on vous
appartient on vient surtout sarah
pandore janssen chaîne youtube du coût
de l'argent bien sûr moi j'ai un compte
dédié à ma famille je filme toute ma
famille de a à z mais part en surf et
enfin tout ce que vous voulez mais on a
quand même notre jardin secret où
parfois il ya des images où ça va trop
loin c'est du privé je coupe et j'aime
et que du contenu poser c'est du tout ce
soit non c'est sur instagram et son
travail pas d'argent avec la à la limite
tu peux tu peux tu peux en parler parce
que ça peut ça peut aider des familles
et tous mes temps par la passe derrière
moi j'aimerais à 14 titres qui trouva sa
dodge cars dont mais c'est l'air du
temps aux ordres c'est alors clair de
leur temps à la forme on n'en parle même
pas on vient d'en parler c'est vrai que
la forme est indigne je trouve mais
c'était plutôt sur le fond ja pression
que voilà on donnait la pression quand
même qu'un enfant trisomique c'était un
drame terrible qu'il fallait tout de
suite s'en séparer il se trouve que moi
je connais des parents qui ont des
enfants trisomiques qui sont des enfants
qui sont adorables qui sont les enfants
qui sont souvent les plus aimées dans la
famille sont à dre des frères et soeurs
qui sont les enfants qui sont des boules
d'amour et dont je pourrais pas concret
sur une impression qu un enfant
trisomique quelques trucs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
liban
alors je lis cette anecdote quand même
me suis à new york avec l'équipe de
production pour des auditions on
recherche des danseurs et des chanteurs
afin de m'entourer pour un concert se
présente une fille c'est madonna c'est
tout à fait ça n'ont et devant le vent
l'a déjà la puissance de ce qu'elle
dégageait
il avait 19 ans et déjà en revêtement
elle était différente des autres donc on
a décidé non pas de la faire danser avec
moi ce qu'était un peu réducteur il faut
le lire et donc gelé mis dans mes
valises je les ramener avec moi paris
bénin pour la présenter à mes
producteurs dans l'idée de lui faire
enregistrer un des choses qu'elle ne
voulait strictement pas faire à l'époque
puisqu'elle voulait faire du théâtre
elle voulait faire du cinéma mais elle
voulait pas chanter et finalement elle
est restée un an à paris on a partagé le
même appartement donc nos
colocataires
tout bien tout honneur la papete
holmenkollen et madonna avec le titre
apporte entre 800 et 1500 euros par jour
encore aujourd'hui ou alors il faut il
faut expliquer ça parce que les gens
comprennent pas facilement
en tout cas je suis un des seuls à
parler de ce genre de chose les gens
n'aiment pas parler de ça il faut dire
que sur bandes sous virage j'en suis le
papa 150 bien sûr des 3 dès que je suis
à autre vers le compositeur interprète
l'éditeur et le produit
donc forcément sur un titre qui a une
résonance mondiale après mozart apporte
un peu de thunes
[Applaudissements]
tél
parce que dire quand le succès arrive
est ce qu'il n'ya pas bah pas d'angle
tout d'un coup d'y aller c'est une bande
de potes mais a de l'argent et oui c'est
beaucoup plus que quand on est seul
qu'est ce qui se passe ya pas
d'engueulades sur les détentions pour
ceux qui n'ont pas vraiment composé bien
sûr l'arrivée d'une pomme une égalité
financière des compensations je connais
tout ça et je le dis en 85 justement
venir on fait tout ça d'ailleurs on a
essayé d'ajuster pour ça se passe bien
et ça s'est pas très bien passé quand
même donc non